I want to revisit something we talked
about earlier in the week
and we talked about it with Angelo
Carrison from Media Matters and we've
talked about it in other contexts
is Fox News actually turning on Donald
Trump
our best assessment up until November
7th was Fox News isn't really turning on
Trump but they'd rather someone else be
the nominee they'd rather be done with
Trump
and they are setting up Escape hatches
where they can hit the eject button if
necessary
I'm starting to wonder whether Fox News
is going more in the direction of openly
turning on Trump now there's a very
interesting clip wherein Stuart Varney
interviews Trump's daughter-in-law Lara
Trump now this is particularly
interesting because Lara Trump is a Fox
News contributor so this is not just a
guest this is a Fox anchor interviewing
a fox employee Lara Trump and he brings
to her Varney does that announcement on
Tuesday night
didn't seem very good it really didn't
seem particularly good and it's
interesting the way this conversation
goes take a look so I'm sure you're very
supportive of of your father-in-law but
those of us on the outside looking at it
it didn't seem as he got the old magic
you know what I mean
oh well I highly disagree with that look
for Donald Trump from the very beginning
from the first day he came down the
escalator in 2015. right that's the
famous speech where he talked about
Mexican rapists in Trump Tower it's
never been about elected officials
politicians people uh you know in the
swamp in DC it's been about the American
people and if you look around the room
last night you had people from all
different walks of life the energy there
at Mar-A-Lago was absolutely incredible
it really did to me feel like the
2015-2016 campaign all over again okay
so this is Trump's daughter-in-law and
the Fox News contributor who is paid for
that commentary that you just saw but
there was no energy in the room I mean
we we looked at the clips the energy was
so bad people were trying to leave and
Mar-A-Lago staff were keeping them in
the room the energy was so bad that
Jonathan Carl from ABC while Trump was
speaking was able to deliver a live
stand-up report not talking particularly
really loudly because it was so dead in
the room so there may be something
different going on I think it's too
early to know remember from a couple
days ago Maria Bartiromo who has been
one of the biggest Trump suck-ups for
years now there's no Trump conspiracy
theory too crazy for Maria she hosted a
segment wherein she brought guests on
and even she made comments that are kind
of like
we might be over Trump that's
the thing that people keep pushing back
on they don't want to go into a whole
nother storm of hate and there is Trump
derangement syndrome right there's
definitely and and I think he started
even that last night he started with the
China virus he started with you know
poking names at DeSantis we've heard
that and people are tired of it look I
also think that you know the santis and
youngin like you said are really the
future of the party right they're in a
generation that I think needs to come
forward and as much as you know his
policies were good Trump's office is in
the first in the first term I don't
think the majority of the country really
wants to go back there I'll tell you I
live in Florida Florida is fully behind
the Santos no matter what Trump wants to
tell you they're fully behind the Santas
you know it's interesting Ivanka Trump
Ivanka Trump yesterday says she's bowing
out of politics yeah which we covered
extensively already so listen I'll leave
the question to you is Fox News Pro
actively bailing on Donald Trump or are
they just leaving themselves an exit let
me know in the comments make sure that
you were subscribed on YouTube three
million of you 3.2 million of you last
month watch the videos
didn't subscribe let's chip away at that
and get to 2 million subscribers make
sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel quick break back after this
I love reading I read every day no
matter how I arrange my schedule I never
have enough time to read all the books
that I want which is why blinkist has
been such an important part of my life
for years now our sponsor blinkist is
the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils them down into
an explainer that you can read or listen
to in just 15 minutes which includes all
the most important takeaways from the
book with blinkist I can absorb the
essence of 15 different books in an
afternoon so I can quickly gather
insights from all sorts of perspectives
make connections have those kind of aha
moments that don't happen so easily
which is why I feel enriched when I use
blinkist blinkist also summarizes
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers and with the
blinkist connect feature my girlfriend
and I can share one account share books
podcasts with each other talk about them
on the go and don't for forget blinkus
makes the perfect holiday gift my
audience can try blinkist free for seven
days and get 25 percent off after that
go to blinkist.com Pacman the link is
down below